سيطر التصعيد الاسرائيلي على المشهد في
الضفه الغربيه خلال ساعات الليل الاخيره
وقد قال مراسلنا ان قوات الاحتلال اقتحمت
بلده بيت فجاره جنوب مدينه بيت لحم كما
اقتحمت بلده كفر قدوم شرق قلقيليه شمالي
الضفه الغربيه ومدينه طوباس شمالي الضفه
ونشر الجيش دوريات مدعومه بجرافك في احياء
عده وسط اطلاق نار كثيف وتحليق طائره
استطلاع في سماء
حسان مسعود من رام الله ينضم الينا مره
اخرى حسان هل من
جديد نبدا من حيث انتهيت سفيان طوباس ما
زالت تشهد اشتباكات عنيفه بين قوات
الاحتلال والمقاومين الفلسطينيين الذين
يتصدون لاقتحام اليات الاحتلال وجنود جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الذي يصطحب معه جرافه
عسكريه ايضا الى المدينه الواقعه شماليه
الضفه الغربيه هذه الاشتباكات ما زالت
مستمره يسمع اصوات لاطلاق النار بشكل مكثف
من قبل المقاومين باتجاه اليات الاحتلال
وتستخدم القنابل محليه الصنع كذلك للتصدي
لهذا الاقتحام الجديد لمدينه طوباس ويبدو
واضحا ان هذا الاقتحام هو من بين
الاقتحامات واسعه التي تنفذها قوات
الاحتلال للمدن الفلسطينيه الكبرى في
الضفه الغربيه لا سما في شمالها كجنين
ونابلس وطولكرم واليوم ياتي هذا الاقتحام
لمدينه طوباس ولكن هذا ياتي ايضا بالتزامن
مع عدد من الاقتحامات التي تنفذها قوات
الاحتلال في مختلف انحاء الضفه الغربيه في
كل من محافظات قلقيليه لا سما في كفر قدوم
وعزوم وكذلك في قراوه بني حسان في محافظه
سلفيت شمال الضفه الغربيه وايضا في محافظه
بلحم تشهد
منطقه طقوع جنوب المحافظه كذلك اقتحاما من
قبل قوات الاحتلال بعد ما انسحبت قبل قليل
فقط من مدينه بيت او من بلده بيت فجار
تحديدا في المحافظه عقب تبادل لاطلاق
النار واقتحام من قبل قوات واليات
الاحتلال اما في القدس فكذلك
تشهد بلده حزمه اقتحاما من قبل قوات
الاحتلال وكذلك كانت قد شهدت مواجهات مع
الشبان الفلسطينيين المقدسيين الذين تصدوا
لاقتحام قوات الاحتلال عبر القاء الحجاره
لكن جيش الاحتلال و كذلك قام بالقاء
القنابل قنابل الغاز والصوت باتجاه الشبان
لتفريقهم اثناء تصديهم لهذا الاقتحام هذا
كله يشير الى استمرار هذه السياسه التي
تتبعها قوات الاحتلال منذ السابع من
اكتوبر بشكل واضح وبشكل مكثف لاقتحامات
ليليه يوميه في الضفه الغربيه في محاوله
لتفادي اي هجمات من قبل الفلسطينيين في
المناطق التي تشهد وجودا لفصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وكتائب المقاومه التي تت ض
لاقتحامات قوات الاحتلال وتحاول ان تحمي
المدن الفلسطينيه في الضفه الغربيه في
اطار ما يوصف
بمحاولات تفادي الهجمات وكذلك الهجوم قبل
الدفاع